The Nvidia GTX 1070 is sure to be a hit
card as it follows in the 970s footsteps
numerically and has an aggressive price
point of
$449 for the Founders Edition and
$379 for the custom versions that will
come later. Steam hardware survey
beware. Does it have the performance to
properly stake a claim to a chunk out of
the comparatively huge amount of PC
consumers wallets?
[Music]
Tunnel Bear is the easytouse VPN service
that lets you use the web as if you're
in one of 20 different countries. Learn
more and try Tunnel Bear for free at the
link in the video description. First,
let's start with specs. The GTX 1070 is
the second card in their new Pascal
lineup. And it features a GP 104 chip
with 1920 CUDA cores compared to the
1080s 2560 and runs at a boost clock of
1683 MHz compared to the 1080 1733 MHz.
It also features the nice new 16nmter
process. Unlike the GTX 1080's shiny new
GDDDR5X memory, the 1070 is still
sporting GDDR5, but is claiming the
title of the world's fastest version of
said memory. As well as running out of
the box at 8 GB per second, that paired
with the new memory compression
algorithm, which gives you effectively
20% additional bandwidth, results in 8
gigs of some pretty damn fast GDR5. But
beyond raw specs, there are some other
features Nvidia has baked into the
Pascal cookie as well, such as
simultaneous multiprojection and anzel,
which make VR gaming and multimonitor
gaming way better and bring gaming
screenshots into basically the future
along with some improvements to Nvidia
VR works. But if you want to hear more
about those, click here to check them
out in the official launch review for
the GTX 1080. I spend more time on them
there. We got our hands on the Founders
Edition, which sounds fancy, but is
really just what Nvidia is calling the
reference version and selling for, as
previously mentioned,
$449. A full 70 bucks more than the MSRP
for base models from add-in board
partners whose cards we might be able to
see at Computex this year, but I expect
more of the 1080s to be shown off than
the 1070s as the launch is so close. The
seemingly DSX inspired shroud features a
similar aesthetic to the silver and
black shrouds with blower style fans
that Nvidia has been using for the past
few generations, but with more angles
this time around. Connectivity is good
as it features HDMI 2.0 for 4K at 60 Hz,
three display port 1.4 connectors for 4K
at 120 Hz or 8K at 60 Hz. Holy crap. And
dual link DVI. SLI is a little confusing
these days because of the introduction
of new types of multiGPU support with
DirectX12. What you need to know for now
is that classic Nvidia SLI only supports
two-way configurations by default and
allows users to request something called
an enthusiast key directly from Nvidia,
which will unlock three-way and four-way
SLI even though it is no longer
recommended by Nvidia. There is more
information to be discussed here like
in-depth looks at MDA, also known as
multi-dis adapter mode, and LDA
explicit, also known as linked display
adapter explicit mode, but we'll cover
that in a future video exploring the
performance differences and general
support of each mode. So stay tuned for
that. Also, just a quick note before
moving on. If it doesn't seem like we
have a bunch of AMD cards in our
testing, it's because their new Polaris
architecture, which is supposed to
compete with Pascal, is right around the
corner. We'll have much more from the
red team when those cards drop. With
that said, let's have a look at how our
benchmarking turned out. We tested at 4K
and 1440p. Even if you're watching this
and have a 1080p monitor, it's better
when wielding this much power to run
your games at higher resolutions. anyway
with something called super sampling to
make things look super nice. We have a
guide on that here. Although we've been
waiting for the VR games market to
mature a bit before reviewing how good
this thing is with the Rift and the
Vive, I did want to investigate what
resolution exactly this card should
actually be aimed at for standard
desktop gaming. We know from the
investigation of the 1080 that the 1080
is a rather capable 4K card, as we kind
of expected. And while the story isn't
the same for the 1070, it's impressive
in its own way. With maxed out settings
at every resolution, it destroyed 1080p
gaming, showing that even with a minor
amount of pulling back on the settings,
you would have a card that can give you
the performance you need for your shiny
new 140 Hz monitor. At 1440p, it kept
flexing its muscles, never dropping
below 60 fps with all of the settings
cranked on whatever the highest preset
was. Then in 4K, it didn't quite sit up
with its bigger brother, but still
managed higher than 30 FPS and every
title with its settings cranked even a
little bit higher with everything put to
the max, even above what the highest
preset in some games were. Okay, so it's
mainly a 1440p card if you're going for
beauty or a 1080p card if you're going
for wild frame rate gaming or a 4K card
if you want to dial back on a fair bit
of different settings or don't mind
gaming at 30 fps. Although I don't
really recommend that if you can avoid
it. At 1440p, it handily beats its
predecessor, the 970. While we did
expect this after the launch, it's still
quite awesome to see a card that isn't
the flagship perform so well. Speaking
of which, what about dollars per frame?
Well, as expected, the 1070 kind of
rocks. The 1080 was already pretty good,
but it was against really big, beastly,
expensive setups at 4K. The 1070, when
put up against more standard competition
and something that you'd expect more
people to run, still performs quite
impressively. We still need to wait for
AMD's Polaris to really see where it
lines up, but for now, I'm quite happy.
For power draw, the entire bench only
drew 216 watts from the wall, which is
ridiculous and gives you borderline
unlimited options for lower wattage
power supplies. Thermals were even lower
than expected as well, sitting at 78° C.
Just wow. In conclusion, the 1070 really
looks like the card it needed to be.
Sure, the 1080 is great, but its cost
was also great. The 1070 is able to
destroy 1080p gaming, which is still the
most popular resolution, and gives
people fantastic options for high
refresh rate monitors, and even gives
out that sweet, sweet nectar, that is
1440p gaming at 60 fps or above. All I
have to say is to those that delayed
upgrading their rigs for the fast past
like few months, and to my random friend
Ryan, it's coming, man. This is very
possibly the card that you were waiting
for. Crunchyroll is a site created by
anime fans for anime fans. They offer
the most current episodes of new shows
straight from Japan like Twin Star
Exorcists and Ace
Attorney. Large collections of the most
popular anime series like One Piece and
Naruto. I'm going to get ripped on so
much for that. And all of the content on
their site is professionally subtitled.
Head over to
crunchyworld.com/ linus and you can sign
up for a 30-day free trial of
Crunchyroll Premium. If you enjoy the
many benefits of premium, like 1080p
streaming, getting new episodes of shows
straight from Japan within an hour of
their premiere, which is like almost the
whole point, and being able to stream
anywhere, anytime on a variety of
devices like your phone, tablet, game
console, or, you know, PC, you can
continue your premium membership to
Crunchyroll for only $6.95 per month. So
again, head over to
crunchyroll.com/inus to check them out.
All right, guys. Thanks for watching. If
you liked it, like it. If you disliked
it and you're like, I'm waiting for
Polaris. That's fine. You can do that.
Subscribe if you want to see the Polaris
videos, which will eventually come out.
And uh yeah, use our affiliate code to
shop on Amazon cuz that's super helpful
whether you're buying Polaris or Pascal,
whichever side of the PE coin you decide
to go with. Uh check out our shirts in
the description down below. And don't
forget to check out the forum. They're
awesome. You can talk about graphics
cards there. Just don't start a flame
war. There's no point in that. Just
constructive discussion. That's what the
form's about. Yeah. Check out this
video. It's the 1080 review. I mentioned
it a few times in this video, but yeah,
these they're kind of sister videos, so
just go check it out.